[Music]
now if you are a french player then the
trap i'm about to show you
against the kings in an attack you must
know
as recently a lot of good players has
fallen for it
after e4
and e6
kings in an attack start with the move
d3
and after over d5
white can follow the main line for a
while
knight to d2
knight to f6
and now knight g to f3
whereupon
we deliver the surprise package
as you can see from the database here
the move which i am going to recommend
namely
bishop to c5
is not there in the top choice
and i think this is where which sets up
the platform for our upcoming trap
as lot of white player caught off guard
as they simply think that
okay black is not threatening knight g4
as we can always respond with d4
so by far if you look at the database
g3 which happens
in more than 2800 games on leeches
and as per the feed day there are more
than 40 games goes into this direction
where i'm afraid
white has straight away
fallen into our trappy territory
the trappy business start with this very
obvious sequence
d captures e4
white has two choices
if he continue with knight captures e4
then this is the easiest one
we first capture on e4
and after pawn takes
yup you got it bishop captures f2
keane takes f2
so at first sight it looks like black is
winning the whole queen
but nope white can regain the queen back
by giving this check
and obvious enough we are going to
retrieve back the queen
so that after bishop takes d7 and bishop
captures d7
when the dust is clear you can clearly
see that
black emerge with a clear pawn advantage
well if you check out here
by far the most popular choice is
d captures e4
which looks more natural in this
position
but i'm afraid
this leads to
a completely lost position
after black's obvious response
knight to g4
[Music]
and
suddenly white realized that f2 is
hanging
and there is no way in the world he can
defend it
now if we consider the top three choices
here
amazingly enough
two of them losing the white queen and
one
loses the piece
let's check out
how we can achieve it
the first move i want to consider is
queen to e2
highestly played but a big time mistake
as black has this very simple sequence
which naps the white queen
bishop captures f2
king to d1 and now this knight shack
where king doesn't have any root to
escape
so by force queen has to take this
knight
and obviously at the end
black get queen against the knight which
is a huge plus
okay let's check out what about other
options
and instead of queen to e2 the second
most popular choice is
bishop to b5 check
whereupon we can play a simple move c6
and the best white can do over here is
to forget about that bishop and castle
on the king side
whereupon black simply gobble up the
piece
just within the eighth move of the game
well last but not least
what happened if your opponent continue
with
bishop to g2 which is the third popular
choice
and against this more or less we have
the same story
bishop captures f2
if king to f1 then we have night fork on
e3
so the natural response is king to e2
but after that
once again this amazing night move
and funny enough queen has three
locations
but neither of them can save her
the best white can do over here is
capture this bishop but after knight
takes queen rook takes knight
once again the dust is clear and the end
result is
black obtained queen for two minor
pieces
which is again
a huge advantage to the black camp
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trap
in the french against the king's indian
attack
remember if your opponent continue with
g3 at this point
then don't forget to punish him with d
captures e4
and it doesn't matter how waver white
recapture
black's early advantageous domination
cannot be denied
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and i
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care